from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Burger King in the US and in
China this is food Wars
hey it's Joe I'm busy working on some
cool new videos for you and not be able
to host today but I want to introduce
you to my good friend Nico I trust Nico
is going to do a fantastic job all the
food Wars heads watching make her feel
welcome take it away Nico
here in China our Burger King drinks
come in three sizes small medium and
large in the US our Burger King drinks
come in four sizes value which we
weren't able to get small medium and
large let's see how much our largest
drink actually contains I'm kind of okay
with it
they're lying to me our Burger King
fries also come in three sizes small
medium and large our fries come in four
sizes value small medium and large let's
weigh our largest rice 120 140 grams
Liars again
this is the second lie I've been told in
like five minutes I think Joe and Harry
have beef with Burger King ever since
hashtag frygate2020 they discovered the
small and medium sizes were the same
size allegedly allegedly I do not want
to get sued but let's see if both of
them actually do weigh the same I don't
think that I have to count every
individual fry because that is a very
big difference I think there's clearly
some discrepancies going on just for fun
let's weigh these value fries these are
98. what's happening what's going on at
Burger King so I guess you can get away
with just ordering a value size for like
way less money if this is what's going
on all chicken fries come in one size
only and should contain six fries
no way to escape from giving us the full
amount here because only six of them
ours is also one size nine chicken fries
one two three four five six seven eight
nine this is the first time the Burger
King has them lied straight to my face
let's begin with our beef burgers we can
start with the king's collection which I
guess are BK's premium Burgers whereas
the Whoppers are known as Emperors but
they're cheaper than the Kings I can
just hear the nationalists starting to
get angry already How could a king be
more powerful and more expensive than an
emperor what gives obviously haven't
localized properly BK you need to know
your audience beginning with the
pastrami Angus it's not something that
you see very often here in China to
begin with so in Chinese the name is
called the big mouse Angus burger
because the burger itself is meant to be
quite a tall burger but this is a very
beautiful burger and I must say I am
very impressed that it has not come to
us sloppy and completely crushed into
paste which was the case that we found
with other fast food chains I'm not
gonna name names
very dense I did have to open my mouth
pretty wide and I can't quite taste the
pastrami but I like that it's there here
we've got the classic Angus you can also
get the spicy version which is what I've
opted for oh
oh that's a spicy palette this is
actually pretty interesting it's not the
Citron spicy kind of heat that I've
gotten used to here eating other
localized burgers in China but this is
more sort of a straight up in your face
heat a lot of black pepper and the
caramelized onions oh they pan very well
in this burger introducing the heavy
cheese beef thing so heavy actually it
even crushed the box that it came in
well hello the spicy bamboo shoots beef
chicken Whopper that is such a long name
it came in this box these are characters
from a massive game in China called the
honor of Kings it's a MOBA the company
that makes this bought Riot games which
made League of Legends the fact that it
has this collab I mean that means
something
I just want to say it tastes very
Chinese in the best possible ways feels
like I'm in Southwest China right now
playing a game of honor of kings and
losing badly
because otherwise how would I have time
to eat burgers if I'm not respawning
final member of the King collection is
the Italian spinach bacon Angus oh one
thing that irks me a little bit about
bacon in burgers in China is that
they're this kind of bacon they're wet
and what's the point of eating bacon if
it's not crispy
oh my God BK burgers are so incredibly
dense they're like the burger versions
of diamonds moving on to our classic
burgers this is the king oyster mushroom
beef Whopper Thai Basil flavor oh my God
not only are there Burgers mouthfuls but
so are the names you could actually see
the oyster mushrooms look right here
let's give this mouthful a mouthful
refuse account I come in the gym about
to do some really heavy lifting
and then
another classic the grilled pineapple
Whopper one gigantic pineapple ring
if I had two more hands so oh the pork
cubes and beef burger who names these
things the pork cubes that it refers to
is
pork neck the meat lovers heaven isn't
it I could do this
feeling like my jaw is about to break
oh yes
wow
that is amazing this pork neck is just
absolutely delicious moving on to our
value section we've got the spicy
Whopper Junior oh look at this little
guy you can also get the pineapple bacon
Whopper Junior also in this size this is
our bacon corner so we have the bacon
King and there is a bacon cheeseburger
and a double bacon cheeseburger I really
want to taste the bacon King
big burger for fast food right that is
heavy too my face is bigger but it
doesn't smell as good as this Bergen
does
it kind of tastes like a burger right
off the grill this is the insane how big
they are now let's move on to the
Whoppers I think these are definitely
Burger King's claim to fame it's what
they're most known for this is the Texas
Double Whopper this kind of looks like
the Mondo Burger from Good Burger
that is not ASMR what's the opposite of
ASMR and the last Whopper we have is The
Impossible Whopper which I actually
think tastes pretty delicious it's like
this looks like a hamburger from like a
play food set I had as a child it just
doesn't look very real
this looks like a monster I do want to
take a bite of the Texas Double Whopper
just because it's got a lot of stuff in
it
that is so good oh my gosh really spicy
and here we have our single Rodeo Clown
King Burger
single Rodeo Burger King pounder all of
them share the exact same words it's
crazy and here we have the single
quarter pound king and the Rodeo Burger
which I think has onion rings in it I
was wrong okay pretend I said the
opposite so this is the Rodeo Burger and
it's got onion rings and what looks like
sticky barbecues on it's just a little
congealed in there
I think it could be good it's just not
very good now let's move on to the
chicken sandwiches or Burgers whichever
you prefer as for chicken you can get
the chicken Whopper coming in classic or
spicy flavors you can get the grilled
pineapple chicken Whopper as well next
we've got the Chicken Big King now the
Big King is a collection and we have
beef which is not exclusive here in
China but chicken and fish are and it's
basically kind of like a Big Mac in that
there are two patties and a bun in the
middle
that's a lot of red this here is the
fruitwood grilled chicken burger spicy
chicken powder the chicken is
threatening to escape
oh yeah the more you chew it the more
you chew it the more flavorful it
becomes and now I can it's it's almost
like a thermometer in my mouth I can
I can feel the spiciness rising up I
swallowed just now and my saliva is
spicy we have the crispy chicken
sandwich but what makes this a sandwich
and this a burger I have no idea there's
also a double version of that
excuse my lettuce that is called the
double chicken burger so if it's a
single it's a crispy chicken sandwich
but if it's a double then it just
becomes something else anyway this also
comes in original or ratan pepper flavor
here we have the chicken version of the
Italian spinach bacon Whopper a surprise
for your
this is new on the menu
The Black Cheese and crispy chicken
sandwich so this thing is not Nori this
is actually a slice of cheddar cheese
that's been dyed black with Squid Ink
because just why not so if you thought
this was weird check this out
this is the black cheese and crispy
chicken burger
most importantly instead of the the bun
that they've replaced it with two pieces
of black cheese mind blown
I think this is basically just an excuse
for you to not feel guilty about eating
a piece of spicy chicken by itself
without the bread it's basically
just there as like tissue to help you
eat this thing we have two chicken
exclusives the original chicken sandwich
and the chicken Junior This shape is
actually very unique and pretty iconic
in a world of circular chicken
sandwiches like this stands out to me
usually the chicken sandwiches I see
look like this just you know nothing
special but this
special BK also offers fish exclusives
here we've got the fish and crisp which
I believe uses a Cod fillet and of
course the fish version of The Big Ang
and of course we also have a pork
section comprising of two burgers the
pork neck and beef burger which I took a
nice big chunk out of before and the
chicken version of this pork burger and
here is our fish option the big fish
this is the smoothest bun I've ever seen
look how shiny and beautiful that is
is not offensive not particularly great
these are all exclusive snacks here in
Burger King China I feel like they're
encroaching on KFC territory a little
bit because all of this is chicken we've
got the Mahala chicken drumstick so Mala
literally just means numb and spicy and
it's referring to the Chinese style of
cooking with the peppercorn which gives
you the numbness and the chili heat oh
wow
I feel like this is probably
the strongest
Mala flavor that I've had thus far on
food Wars starting to turn my tongue
numb and quite pleasantly surprised here
we got the petite version the Mala
chicken wings this here the king hot and
spicy chicken wings
oh man I much prefer over the Mala to be
honest this is a lot more balanced it's
more flavorful it's meatier so these are
called The Spicy flavor chicken slices
apparently it's four millimeter thin
slices of chicken breast it just kind of
looks like mini chicken nuggets doesn't
it this is the chicken box which
contains a medley of what we sampled
earlier so Burger King also has other
versions of the bucket the Box whatever
you'd like to call it they've got the
King chicken bucket the king bucket and
the King bucket plus they're basically
the BK version of the party bucket or
family bucket for those of you who could
not get enough of The Black Cheese you
can also get it as a standalone piece
just one piece of good old cheddar
cheese dyed black with Squid Ink oh BK
we are so funny
you can always opt for the garden salad
and here in Chinese it actually says
mama is shouting at you telling you to
eat more veggies and these are our
exclusive side options we have onion
rings
Don't Mind If I Do
you're soggy
and we also have mozzarella sticks which
I feel like at this point are fully
congealed back into their like frozen
state
these were supposed to come with a
marinara sauce I don't think I got one
we also have Mott's applesauce as a side
but they unfortunately ran out and here
are our
exclusive sauces sauce talk we have
Buffalo Ranch honey mustard and zesty I
know what pretty much all these sauces
taste like except for zesty I'm very
confused as to what this could be let's
watch this one for you guys just so you
can see what it looks like on my skin
tone
this is the most disturbing stupid thing
I've ever done
horseradishi I feel like zesty gives me
like ooh zesty this is like oh
let's see it's nasty time for desserts
we can start with the Ovaltine King
Fusion this comes in original strawberry
and brown sugar bubble flavor
the Ovaltine was the little sort of
brown flakes on top that's what tastes
like milk chocolate not bad it's not as
sweet as I thought it would be Ovaltine
King Fusion brown sugar bubble Edition
very elusive Instinct where are they oh
here we go
delicious Once Upon a Time this was the
Hokkaido flavor ice cream waffle cone
it tastes like melted ice cream I can't
tell
if you say socato
I'm none the wiser this is the crispy
chocolate and nuts sundae Haagen-Dazs
Ben and Jerry get out the way BK's in
town look at that that looks Lux and
look at how much chocolate is in here
this is basically half a bar of
chocolate in ice cream there's nothing
that could be better than this I think
it's peanut I'm not sure who cares oh
it's delicious
and the strawberry pulp sundae actual
strawberry in the sundae Color Me
impressed this pie comes in two
different flavors dark chocolate or
mango and coconut let me check which one
this is I think it's a Telltale sign I
think it's probably the chocolate deep
fried chocolate what could go wrong
these are called crispy sick milk bars
it's creamy but it doesn't really taste
like mud this is the soft Mochi ice
cream and it comes in two flavors
strawberry yogurt and salted egg
wow
it's kind of like a custard
this kind of tastes like what would
happen if he took the heart out of a
moon cake and liquefied it and just
drank it oh my god I think I'm seeing
stars from my blood sugar spiking
let's talk about desserts at Burger King
in the U.S you can get a soft serve cup
a soft serve cone or the Hershey's
Sunday pie this was one of my favorite
things ever as a kid I would always get
it every time we went to Burger King
look at this it literally says yum on
every side because it's that good they
look exactly the same as when I was
little
that is so
delicious these are the exclusive drinks
on the Burger King China menu looks
weird doesn't it just looks like seven
up but this is actually coconut flavored
lemon sparkling drink peach flavor
oolong tea this is the brown sugar Boba
milk tea you can get this hot or cold
and also if you take away the Bubba
balls it will just basically become the
Hong Kong style milk tea which you can
also get hot or cold
the crispy chocolate low top milk tea
you can also get Ceylon tea which is
just black tea or hot or cold soy milk
which this is you can get juice too
grapefruit juice and mixed berries juice
next we have the king coffee collection
and this is just honestly the cutest cup
ever you can get your latte or your flat
white your hazelnut latte or cappuccino
in this very very cute squat cup or if
you don't like being cute you can just
opt for a regular sized Americano drink
exclusives in the US include Coke Zero
Sprite Zero barks root beer Dr Pepper
Fanta orange Mellow Yellow Powerade Zero
High Seafood punch and high C pink
lemonade it's a fast food restaurant so
of course they also offer milkshakes and
Frozen beverages we have a vanilla
milkshake a chocolate milkshake an Oreo
milkshake a chocolate Oreo milkshake
this is a frozen Fanta wild cherry and
this is supposed to be a frozen Coke but
it's another Frozen Fanta Wild Cherry
we've been putting the people at Burger
King through a lot today so some
mistakes were made they also supposedly
offer a strawberry milkshake but that
wasn't available at our Burger King
it was a better vanilla milkshake all
right let's try this Frozen Fanta Wild
Cherry is this this is basically just a
slushie right
that's very good these are Burger King
China's exclusive breakfast menus okay
so just like McDonald's and KFC Burger
King also does a pretty decent breakfast
menu here in China not quite as
extensive as KFC and nowhere near as
exhaustive as McDonald's but what Burger
King has over both of them is the cross
sandwich I love crossover sandwiches
although it's kind of weird how in China
they're not cooled by their actual names
but they're called croissants so this is
the standard cross sandwich the or as we
call it here in China the pork egg and
cheese croissant next we have the
Pastrami and scrambled egg croissant in
Chinese we would call it young tea which
kind of means like western style of uh
BK I mean obviously it's Western Star
but the fact that you know you have
pastrami and scrambled egg this
combination just seems very very foreign
to Chinese culture and I think in a cool
way this is great just staying true to
BK's roots
hmm I love pastrami what you got here
the beef egg cheese croissant and last
but not least in our croissant series
butter croissant which is
all right BK you made this a seasonal
menu item I don't understand what it has
to do with Seasons there's literally
just two pieces of your cross on bread
this is the double egg and beef burger
two eggs with two beef batties
sandwiched in between no bread
whatsoever oh there is no way you can
safely get away with eating this without
making a mess of yourself now onto your
more standard fare the grilled beef
cheese muffin you can also get this
grilled beef cheese egg muffin oh now we
have something special the tamagoyaki
and fruit would flavor grilled chicken
muffin look at that
oh this is delicious well I highly
recommend it and if you don't want beef
skin your muffin you can get it as a
cheese egg muffin if you don't want egg
nor beef then you can get it as a
grilled pork muffin BK also has an
assortment of breakfast wraps the
scrambled egg and cheese sausage wrap
Beijing style roasted chicken wrap no
Lee
just the cucumbers and the tiemian sauce
we're missing the last item on the Holy
Trinity of the Beijing Star wrap
you know it's it's inoffensive that's
all I can say this is something special
salted egg yolk chicken wrap The Salted
egg yolk is actually smeared all over
the chicken here Ah that's very
ingenious of BK
there's no mistaking that salted egg wow
texture Wise It's like um it's an egg
yolk that has been matured kind of like
a fine vintage egg if that makes sense
uh last but not least we've got the
mixed vegetable and roasted chicken wrap
and of course we've got to have Congee
two types this is Century egg and this
is salted egg gives the century egg a
try
although yeah it's pretty strong there's
a very very fine line between tasty and
stinky and Century egg firmly Shadows
that light I've never had salted egg
yolk in a Congee before
ponji is not my favorite breakfast item
but I think with this kind of flavoring
that yeah I can dig it
and of course on every single breakfast
menu there's gonna be crispy Chinese
color the yotel they all look the same
no matter which five food chain you go
to BK also has a sunny side up egg
although again you can't really tell
where the sun is oh this is pretty
interesting the bean paste glutinous
rice ball we call them madwar which kind
of means Sesame pile a mound these have
a really interesting history they
originated in the Tango this year over a
thousand years ago and were served up in
the Imperial Kitchen and actually you'll
find that a lot of traditional Chinese
desserts especially here in Beijing were
originally served to the emperor the
sort of stuff that we eat now
foreign back in the old days centuries
ago when Emperors ruled China history in
a mouthful
I'd say it's okay it's probably not the
tastiest Sesame Mound I've ever had but
you know this isn't made for Emperors
because otherwise I'll be off with your
head egg bacon pie
oh that's pretty tasty the nostalgia's
coming back in I just remember growing
up in the UK and then going down to
Greg's and getting a nice pasty in the
morning oh I've actually never had
Burger King breakfast in the U.S our
breakfast sandwiches all come with
different variations of sausage bacon
ham egg and cheese and they come in
either a croissant biscuit or melt form
we couldn't get the Melt form but we do
have the croissant and the biscuit in
the loaded versions loaded just means
that they come with all of the toppings
they look like they're about to burst so
I believe that's true in America this is
a biscuit
the salt that just got into I like I
felt all the moisture in my body just
disappeared with that one bite that was
crazy here are all the different
breakfast sandwich combinations that you
can make at Burger King in the U.S so
you can also get the enormous burrito or
its baby if you don't want that much of
a burrito before like 10 a.m We also
have sweeter breakfast options like
these pancakes with a sausage and the
French toast sticks
I could literally feels like I am
chewing gum right now that is crazy how
stretchy and bouncy it is right now they
smell
like they were just refried it's also
chewy just like the pancakes but a lot
less disturbing in the mouth
so Burger King entered China in 2005
which actually makes it late to the game
KFC and macades have already been here
for a decade by that point and Chinese
consumers know what western fast food is
like already BK cultivates a slightly
different image one of slightly more
Prestige and you'll find them mostly in
major cities top tier cities like
Beijing Shanghai less so in smaller
cities I feel
Burger King has the has the mutation of
being somewhat fresher when it comes to
ingredients maybe it's considered on the
more fresher side when it comes to
American fast food even though it's
probably not it's pretty funny in the
past Burger King has been criticized for
its bad customer service for its uh rude
servers and the main thing was you
couldn't even complain because they
didn't have a complaints hotline they
kind of like take it or leave it
convenient speed of service that totally
depends on your specific Burger King is
it fast food still Yes you still get the
food in around 10 to 15 minutes it's
just will you be getting what you
ordered
who knows that's part of the fun I would
say that Burger King out of McDonald's
and KFC is the least localized and so
they're cultivating maybe the image of
being a gourmet burger jointer sort of a
go-beteen regular fast food chain and an
actual gourmet burger restaurant when it
comes to how they adapt to local tastes
I feel like there's nothing that special
on the menu it's pretty normal American
fast food they did have that one special
Texas whopper which I've never been to
Texas so I can't really speak on how
accurate that is but it tasted really
good so in terms of competition bug
gigging is actually fist in China behind
KFC McDonald's Wallace burger and
chicken which is a local brand and decos
another local brand McDonald's has to be
Burger King's biggest rival as we're
filming this in early May we've gotten
word that Burger King is closing around
300 to 400 locations
a Whopper is 27 Yen that's
3.92 in the US a whopper cost 7.89 which
is in a hundred and one point three
percent price increase compared to
China's Whopper
make it a meal with a medium fry and a
medium drink and the price goes up to 40
Yen which is 5.8 add a medium fry and a
drink to your order and that brings the
price up to 11.99 which is in 106.7
increase in price and if you want to
upgrade to large then that's 44 Yen
which is
6.38 make it a large in the US and the
price goes up to 12.59 which is a 97
increase in price just in general I
found that Burger King tends to be
slightly more expensive than McDonald's
and KFC
China's Burger King doesn't share its
nutritional information but here are a
few noteworthy moments from the last
couple of years in 2020 Burger King
apologized to its customers when it was
reported that some of their locations
had sold expired food so a Burger King
in Nanchang which is a major city in
Eastern China had used expired
ingredients to make its burgers and get
this there was actually video footage of
Staff replacing the date labels on the
expired bread with new ones and another
Burger King in exactly the same city did
the same thing with expired chicken
Burger King responded with and I quote
our mismanagement has betrayed the trust
of consumers to Burger King and we
express our deepest apologies for this
this caused China to probe further into
outer U.S fast food chains like KFC and
McDonald's Burger King along with
McDonald's was sued last year for using
pfas or forever chemicals in their
packaging forever chemicals it's in my
body forever Consumer Reports found pfas
in the French toast sticks bags Whopper
wrappers and chicken nugget bags we ate
like two out of those three things today
oh my God pfas are chemicals that are
hard to break down and last a long time
which are not good for the environment
and pfas exposure has been linked to
health problems in humans Burger King
has responded in saying quote the Burger
King brand has required that any added
perfluoro alkyl and polyfloral alkyl
substances pfas be phased out from all
approved guest-facing packaging
materials globally by the end of 2025 or
sooner that's not soon enough is it in
my food or not is it in my food or not
is it like touching them
is it in the gloves
it in this little crown that I've been
wearing all day I'm so stressed out